منار ميقال ان العالم جميل لكي يوضع في
كتاب فنحن لمن دورون لصناعه الكتاب لكي
تاليف الكتاب لانتاج الكتاب لكي انقل الى
الاخرين بشكل رؤيه
مساهمه في هذا الملف حول الشاعر سعد يوسف
وهذه الاولى باريس
فيها 10 قصائد من قصائدي
وهذه انطولوجيا للشعر العربي المعاصر من
انجاز الشاعر استاذ عبد القادر الجنابي
صدرت في باريس ايضا حول القصيده العربيه
المعاصره فيها ايضا مجموعه من القصائده
[موسيقى]
اليوم في هذا المحيط من وسائل الاتصال
والمواقع اللي
يتجاور يتجاور على منصات فيها العالم
والجاهل
الموضوع امبير الشرعيه
يبدو كان
تخفض كثيرا امام هذه الموجه من وسائل
الاتصال الان يعني
وحتى النصوص التي تكتب على هذه الوسائل
على مقدار من الهشاشه
سلبا على العمل الابداعي العمل الجاد
العمل البحث العمل اللي فيه يعني
انا نعول على التاريخ
ولم يتاكد
حتى هذه اللحظه ان كاتبا او شاعر مهما جدا
من الفيسبوك
حقيقه يمكن ان يبدا هناك لكن ينبغي ان
يستكمل صورته في سياقات اخرى وفي وسائل
اخرى كتاب لا غنى عنه وهذه الوائل
[موسيقى]
اله جديده من من الالات المعرفه عن العكس